as angela merkel's chief of staff horn
or pol fala was a deal maker and
mediator he reconciled disputes and
competing interests among the cabinet
ministers he also coordinated the
government's relations with the federal
states and community groups that was
then now just months after winning
re-election as a member of parliament
boeuf a la is quitting it looks like he
may be taking a lobbying job at Deutsche
Bahn as a board member what a lobbyist
does is trying to persuade the
government to do what his corporation
wants I think what makes this case also
different is that he mr. Poe fala is not
only going to any company but to a
public company where apparently this job
was just created for him so that arises
the question how public companies are
creating jobs for outgoing politicians
poor fella is not the first German
politician to cause controversy with a
career move shortly after gerhard
schröder stopped being Chancellor he got
a job at the Russian energy giant
Gazprom and former Transport Minister
Mattias vis mom on the right here went
on to head the auto industry association
various NGOs slam such career moves
particularly the speed with which
politicians ceased to serve the people
and start to serve big business